oh
les voix
l'aiea
les mots
cela
et
bienvenue à tous sur les chaînes
parlementaires émission spéciale de
parlement hebdo consacré à l'ensemble
des mesures et des temps forts politique
de cette semaine une semaine après les
attentats du 13 novembre dernier
et pour parler de cette semaine très
dure pour le gouvernement un ministre
était avec toujours marie le guen
bonjour bonjour secrétaire d'état aux
relations avec le parlement merci d'être
avec nous alors alors nous parlons on
apprend cette cette attaque
cette prise d'otages contre un hôtel un
grand hôtel de bamako au mali c'est une
région où la france est présente avec le
dispositif remarquable ce que vous avez
des informations c'est la guerre partout
non j'ai pas d'information particulière
mais on voit bien que on est devant une
guerre mondialisé et donc il y a deux
façons différentes mais partout des
affrontements avec cette même idée de
terrorisme de massacre
avec des gens fanatisés ce qui fait que
nous ne sommes évidemment pas dans les
guerres conventionnelles habituel
mais c'est une guerre avec un aspect
mondialisée x a peut être le câble qui
est des français qui sont otages je ne
connais pas aujourd'hui la liste des
otages évidemment mais on peut imaginer
en tout cas il est possible que il y est
y compris ça semble deux compatriotes
voilà bon mais il ya eu un attentat vous
en souvenez en egypte il y en a eu un
qui est touché l'egypte et là et là et
la russie il ya eu un attentat à
beyrouth celle des attentats en turquie
il ya des menaces sur l'ensemble de
l'europe
il y a partout un certain nombre de gens
fanatisés qui
cherchent à semer la terreur alors on va
revenir évidemment sur toute la semaine
qui a été marquée à je le disais sur le
plan politique et sur le plan évidemment
parlementaire et ça commence lundi avec
un hommage au parlement lundi à midi la
france s'est arrêtée au sénat l'ensemble
du personnel et des sénateurs ont vécu
cette minute de silence
ensemble à l'assemblée nationale au
match de claude bartolone sur le perron
et puis un peu plus tard
réuni à versailles vous y étiez jean
marie le guen avec le président de la
république les parlementaires ministres
tout aussi rendu un hommage aux victimes
cette réunion des parlementaires à
versailles vous l'avez vécue comme on
avait l'impression d'un d'un espèce de
de moment très intense d'émotion
oui bien sûr c'était une très forte
émotion on était encore dans la sous-
choc de la tacc on commençait à voir la
tête
des victimes les conditions dans
lesquelles s'était passée donc il y
avait à la fois une émotion très forte
et puis
une émotion aussi de la capacité de
réaction du gouvernement de l'état
on était en place et déjà dans l'axé
bien sûr dès le vendredi soir vous savez
il ya eu un conseil des ministres sur à
minuit le président la république s'est
exprimé s'étaient déjà exprimés avaient
trahi ce temps de la politique à des
remises et leurs émotions
non c'est oui alors avec la politique
avec un grand p et recense où
effectivement des responsables et qu'ils
ont été élus dans le cadre de la
république sont là pour porter un
certain nombre de politiques publiques
de réaction d' exprimer aussi ce que
pense la nation c'était le rassemblement
de ce congrès c'était le discours du
président s'étaient le président et le
parlement dont sénateurs est à peu près
bien est-ce que les réunir vers ça et
c'était une obligation constitutionnelle
où c'était le voeu du président de la
république non c'était pas du tout une
obligation constitutionnelle c'était là
pour le coup une opportunité
inconstitutionnel de façon à s'adresser
solennellement à la nation et le faire
dans un cadre républicain
et donc c'était aussi l'application et
je dois dire que de ce point de vue là
la séance du congrès la prise de parole
de la plupart des intervenants a été
quelle que soit leur sensibilité de très
bon niveau
voilà justement devant les
parlementaires réunis en congrès
françois hollande a donc pris des
mesures exceptionnelles
il a décrété l'état d'urgence sur tout
le territoire et donné l'ordre aux
chasseurs de continuer les bombardements
français dans le sel syrien la france
est en guerre a dit le président la
république
la france est en guerre les actes commis
vendredi soir à paris et près du stade
de france sont des actes de guerre ils
ont fait au moins 129 morts et de
nombreux blessés
il constitue une agression contre notre
pays contre ses valeurs contre sa
jeunesse contre son mode de vie
ils sont le fait d'une armée djihadistes
de groupe des ch qui nous combat parce
que la france est un pays de libertés
parce que nous sommes la patrie des
droits de l'homme
jean-marie le guen est ce que cette
cette nuit du 13 novembre ces attentats
marque un tournant dans le quinquennat
écoutez une rupture non je ne crois pas
parce que en fait beaucoup de choses
même si l'émotion et la manifestation
est sans doute là l'ampleur de la
réponse n'était pas là mais le temps
nous connaissions aussi cette menace le
premier ministre avait l'occasion et
d'autres me de l'intérieur le président
république s'était exprimé après les
attentats du mois de janvier pour dire
combien il était inquiet sur la
possibilité qu'il y ait une réplique aux
attentes à janvier que nous étions dans
un phénomène global évidemment tragédie
à ce niveau qu'il faut je suis une
partie considérable de notre jeunesse
dans des conditions absolument
abominable est un élément qui marquera
tout tout tout les tous les français et
donc évidemment on sera des conséquences
à des conséquences terre dans la
mobilisation des moyens de l'état avec
l'état d'urgence loi que nous avons voté
à l'assemblée nationale et que nous
allons voter cet après midi au sénat qui
va à la fois prorogé dans le temps c'est
à dire aller jusqu'à la fin février
globalement sur le donnait la
possibilité constitutionnelle à l'état
d'agir dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
jusqu'à la fin février
mais il n'y a pas simplement la
prolongation il ya aussi une plus grande
efficacité donné à tous est heureusement
un brit air c'est un vrai tournant pour
la gauche également ce tournant
sécuritaire
il va aussi modifier la donne dans votre
parti non je d'abord nous faisons parce
que nous sommes en responsabilité à tous
les sens du terme responsabilités parce
que nous sommes un gouvernement mais en
responsabilité devant l'histoire et
devant la protection nécessaire des
français mais c'est un vrai changement
de culture quand même non ça fait un
bouton que à gauche
à régler cette question a d'abord sur
les problèmes de sécurité ça fait
maintenant 6 7 ans sur les questions de
sécurité
nous sommes sur la question de l'analyse
de la menace là aussi nous avions été je
pense assez éclairé est-ce que la prise
de conscience de nous tous pas des
appareils politiques etc
mais les appareils politiques aussi
est-ce que à part quelques-uns tout le
monde avait bien intégré le ao la
hauteur de niveau de la menace mais nous
tous dans notre vie quotidienne dans
notre façon de parler d'envisager les
choses de voir l'avenir et c'est
peut-être qu'il y avait un certain
décalage entre ce que disaient les gens
qui sont dans le cadre des forces de
police et de renseignement qui attirer
notre attention
un certain nombre de responsables ce que
disait le premier ministre qui n'a cessé
de répéter ces derniers mois que nous
étions toujours devant le visage
l'intérieur le président la république
aussi à son rythme qui est le sien
donc voilà alors maintenant il ya une
mise à niveau j'allais dire un peu
général encore que quand il hier le
premier ministre est obligé de dire un
certain nombre de choses sur les menaces
dit bien revenir il est bien qu'on va y
revenir jean marie le guen et je
voudrais qu'on reprenne un petit peu
l'ordre des choses avec françois
hollande qui a pris par surprise un
petit peu quand même la droite lorsqu'il
a annoncé un certain nombre de mesures
et notamment cette réforme de la
constitution et nous devons aller
au-delà de l'urgence et j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi à cette question
j'estime en conscience que de vous faire
évoluer notre constitution pour
permettre aux pouvoirs publics d'agir
conformément à l'état de droit contre le
terrorisme de guerre cette guerre d'un
autre type face à l'adversaire nouveau
appel un régime constitutionnel
permettant de gérer l'état de crise
alors cette réforme que veut le
président de la république c'est une
réforme de la constitution
est-ce que ça se passe obligatoirement
par congrès où ça pourrait être aussi
par voie référendaire
écoutez je pense que là ça doit se faire
logiquement par contre 1 à lorient on
peut rien exclure puisque il ya une
autre logique d'adoption mais le souhait
du président la république est très
clairement de faire des propositions qui
rassemble les français et au-delà
évidemment la représentation nationale
si jamais un des conférenciers invités
aujourd'hui pour terreau verra bien mais
je n'imagine pas je pense que en
conscience on est dans l'efficacité et
l'efficacité c'est à dire donner les
moyens dans le cadre de l'état de droit
jusqu'à présent je pense qu'il ya une
majorité républicaine à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat qui va à la fois
dans le sens de des mesures de plus
grande efficacité et évidemment tout
ceci dans le respect de l'état de droit
mais certains s'interrogent notamment
drogue sur la nécessité de réviser la
constitution est ce que cette révision
constitutionnelle est indispensable au
renforcement de la sécurité des français
elle l'est à plusieurs titres d'abord
parce que la loi de 55 celle des que
dans l'état d'urgence a été déclaré
constitutionnellement applicable je suis
désolé de faire un petit peu de droit
mais le conseil constitutionnel moment
où il disait mais oui elle a beau est de
55 et d'avant 58 c'est à dire la vème
république cette loi peut fonctionner
voilà ce qu'a dit le conseil
constitutionnel il est dit mais nous
n'avons pas pour autant juger de la
constitutionnalité de cette loi c'est à
dire son fonctionnement était
constitutionnelle son application et des
constitutionnel donc il forme depuis
je suis désolé mais comme ça enfin enfin
le petit cours d'éducation civique
voilà depuis 2008 il ya ce qu'on appelle
la qpc la question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité c'est à dire que
demain vous faites un procès sur ces
sujets et dans le cadre du procès vous
dites mais est ce que la loi que l'on
veut m'appliquer et bien constitutionnel
je vais donc le demander au conseil
constitutionnel et vous avez le droit de
le demander et donc demain il y aura
évidemment des contestations rien
d'aller jusqu'à écouter voilà justement
pour le patron des députés implique un
rien produit ne justifie de réviser la
constitution et côté quant à la
proposition de révision de la
constitution rien eu ça ce stade ne
semble la justifier notre notre
constitution offre clairement tous les
outils juridiques pour faire face à
toutes les situations
alors que répondez-vous à christian
jacob qui lie notre constitution offre
déjà tous ses moyens
non mais de ce point de vue je pense
qu'il est il est revenu un petit peu en
arrière quelques heures après et donc il
y a
la nécessité est l'opportunité sur
différents sujets de constitutionnaliser
voilà pourquoi ouvrir la porte à la
droite sur toutes les discussions
possibles mais nous souhaitons qu'il y
ait un rassemblement de tous les
républicains donc ça va être des preuves
le président la république l'a dit très
clairement à versailles et jaillit dans
les propositions qu'il a faites on voit
bien qu'il avait déjà entendu ce que
disait un certain nombre de
parlementaires de l'opposition
et donc ce qui nous paraît être efficace
justifié est possible dans le cadre de
l'état de droit nous sommes prêts
effectivement à l'intégrer dans une
démarche constitue également sur le
calendrier a priori ça serait pour cause
cette réforme constitutionnelle bas nous
souhaitons aller le plus vite possible
c'est une question là aussi d'efficacité
dans le cadre de la constitution c'est
une carte de garantie des droits publics
et donc nous pensons que il y aura un
texte avant la fin de l'année et que
celui ci pourrait être adoptée le plus
tôt possible mais c'est sans doute à la
fin de l'état d'urgence
tellement il a été votée c'est à dire
fin février début mars on peut espérer
avoir une réforme constitutionnelle donc
un texte pour la fin janvier un texte
qui arrive en conseil des ministres mais
met d'accord oui et une adoption pour la
fin février a priori avec le
rassemblement d'un congrès à versailles
c'est bien ce que vous dites ou
absolument il ya aussi le plan
international françois hollande s'est
exprimé avec un changement aujourd'hui
de stratégie finie la stratégie du ni
dèche ni syrie ni bachar el-assad
écoutez président de la république et
puis vous réagi c'est justement le
terrorisme nous le combattons en irak
pour permettre aux autorités de ce pays
de restaurer leur souveraineté sur
l'ensemble du territoire et en syrie
nous cherchons résolument inlassablement
une solution politique dans laquelle
bachar al assad ne peut constituer
l'issue mais notre ennemi notre ennemi
en syrie cdh
mais il faut un rassemblement de tous
ceux qui peuvent réellement lutter
contre cette armée terroriste dans le
cadre d'une grande et unique coalition
c'est à quoi
nous travaillons c'est dans cet esprit
que je rencontrerai dans les prochains
jours le président obama et le président
poutine pour unir nos forces et
atteindre un résultat qui pour l'instant
est encore renvoyé à trop longtemps la
france aux côtés des russes et donc de
bachar el-assad la france ne disait pas
ça françois landrier pas forcément ça il
ya un changement de stratégie de la
position française ou pas non je pense
que les choses bougent
mais la position française nous ne
sommes pas à côté de bachar el-assad a
en tout cas nous travaillons avec les
russes nous voulons être mais tout le
monde a bougé les attentes a gelé
rappelé et l'attentât de l'airbus et
l'attentât de paris c'est l'attentât de
beyrouth et donc tout le monde bouge
c'est à dire que vous aviez remarqué que
qui bombardé des ch qui m'ont bardèche
avant les attentats
les etats unis la france points les
russes bombardé la syrie mais plutôt
l'opposition dit plus modéré que des ch
il y avait très peu de frappes sur neige
depuis quelques jours certes
d'instruction notamment après ce qui
s'est passé dans le sinaï la sphère de
l'airbus
les russes combarde massivement tech
massivement dahesh ce qui est une
évolution
nous nous sommes aussi en évolution
parce que nous avons toujours s'il en
syrie nous bombarde y en des chenaux
bambach dion pas monsieur à sable donc
notre adversaire prioritaire et
militaires étaient d'ores et déjà des ch
nous ce que nous disons nous continuons
à le dire c'est que à la fin du
processus
d'abord il n'y aura pas que de
l'affrontement militaire il faudra une
solution politique et que de cette
solution politique
elle n'est pas possible non pas pour des
raisons morales mais aussi pour des
raisons morales mais pas pour des
raisons morales elle nie pas possible
que monsieur bachar al-assad reste le
chef de l'est la syrie quand il aura tué
250 mille personnes dans les sons pop ce
qui veut dire qu'il y aura beaucoup
si rien une majorité de syriens qu'ils
n'accepteront pas de voir monsieur bacha
à la tête de l'état d'une scierie apaisé
donc c'est sous c'est tout ce que de
maison et elle n'avait pas la solution
m'acharne c'est un des problèmes il a
même été à l'origine du problème et
bachar n'est pas la solution mais à côté
de ça c'est des choses notre adversaire
très clairement
alors on va revenir sur le plan
intérieur puisque l'union sacrée pas si
sacré n'aura pas duré longtemps sifflé
hué vociférations la séance de questions
d'actualité de mardi a été très
mouvementée certains députés notamment à
droite ont interpellé le premier
ministre à plusieurs reprises ambiance
électrique dans l'hémicycle
malgré le deuil national et l'appel à
l'union du premier ministre
je ferai tout pour que l'unique et
l'union sacrée soient préservés alors
mesdames et messieurs qui représentait
la nation de la majorité et de
l'opposition
soyons dignes soyons dignes à la hauteur
des français
soyons des patriotes rassemblaient pour
abattre le terrorisme
sur les bancs de l'opposition l'heure
est aux reproches et au mais quand
christiane taubira s'apprête à prendre
la parole monsieur le député patrick
bloche
alors qu'il évoque la naturalisation des
étrangers
le ton monte entre philippe meunier et
le chef de l'exécutif
il est tout aussi important d'accorder
la nationalité française avec parcimonie
or depuis l'élection de françois
hollande le nombre d'un annette ne te
naturalisation augmente sans cesse
ma question est donc direct allez vous
sans plus attendre voir votre politique
afin de rendre plus restrictives les
conditions permettant d'obtenir la
nationalité française
la confusion que vous opérez dans votre
question le fait de rendre par les
propos que vous tenez tout étranger
suspect ça vous nous trouverez toujours
devant pour dire non non précisément je
veux rappeler
le soli trottoirs de paris monsieur le
député et dans la salle du bataclan il
vous plait il y a eu des étrangers qui
ont été tués il ya eu des français
d'origine étrangère
il ya eu peut-être même monsieur le
député et français qui avaient acquis
leur nationalité
et parce que moi par mille autres je
fais partie de ceux qui ont décidé un
jour de devenir français parce que
j'aime ce pays
par dessus tout je le permettrais jamais
cet amalgame c'est un amalgame qui met
en cause les valeurs de notre pays
alors que s'est-il passé ce jour là
visiblement est-ce que vous pensez que
certains dans la droite ne tiennent pas
suffisamment leurs troupes
je pense que il y à eut d'abord les
attitudes franchement indignés on a été
on a été submergée de témoignages de nos
concitoyens de quelques sensibilités qui
soit disant mais qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que c'est que cette façon de
rompre le rapport de dignité dont nous
avons besoin aujourd'hui que c'est
indigne d'un élu de la république
je pense que vraiment et certains ont un
esprit
certains vous qui jouez bien les choses
oui j'ose gère voit bien que la manière
dont madame taubira a été traitée la
manière dont des dès le début quand le
premier pour juste à côté de lui donc
dès le début il prend la parole pour
répondre de façon très très clair et
très posée à la situation il ya un
brouhaha des invectives son intervention
et vous en souvenez a été interpellé par
mais c'est tout ça est bien trop tard et
c est donc d invectives permanente qui
rendent d'ailleurs la réponse quasiment
difficile et donc voilà oui il ya eu une
vision qui n'est pas à la hauteur de la
situation des calculs
calcul électoral il m'a bien vous allez
quand même très étonné de voir arriver à
cette question très très d'une façon
notable
trois têtes de liste madame pécresse
pour l'île de france monsieur wauquiez
intervenir avec essentiellement un
rapport de 2 go fait de la politique
politicienne
c'était le dispositif qui était à donner
collectivement me semble-t-il par ce
groupe de l'opposition au lieu de poser
des questions ce qui est parfaitement
logique façon de choses étaient plutôt
de le relancer l'idée était de relancer
la polémique est donc cette vision
polémique est un peu politicienne
effectivement à un moment où les
français attendent est tout à fait autre
chose à créer je crois entre
l'opposition est bon on a bien vu aussi
qu'un certain nombre d'interventions sur
le fond soit disant sur le fond y
compris du président des républicains
qui est interdit il y avait de l'huile
sur le feu sous l'eau alors que j'en
sais rien en tout cas il n'a rien fait
pour j'ai entendu différentes
personnalités dans l'opposition certains
appelaient à l'unité nationale
d'autres voulaient absolument en finir
avec l'unité nationale et mener des
polémiques
d'autant plus me semble-t-il un ding
dong que non seulement elles étaient
décalés dans le temps mais venant de
gens qui en son temps n'avait pas pris
leurs responsabilités en matière de
sécurité
vous me dire ce que vous en pensez très
court claude bartolone président de
l'assemblée nationale dit que dans ces
cas là il ne faudrait pas retransmettre
les questions d'actualité à la
télévision le jour où il ya une grâce à
de dirhams et c'est peut-être une
prérogative qu'on pourrait donner au
président c'est à dire m'enfin je pense
que l'effet serait tout aussi terrible
c'est à dire que on se dirait que
vraiment ça voilà je comprends que ils
se disent si j'avais eu un bouton pour
suspendre
la retransmission j'aurais bien
volontiers appuyé sur tout ça c'est un
réflexe que je comprends est ce que
c'est possible je n'en suis pas sûr
allez hop à ce mercredi le climat
s'apaise un tout petit peu les mercredis
le ton est redescendu d'un cran
l'assemblée nationale en profite pour
rendre hommage aux forces de l'ordre qui
viennent tout juste de mener une
opération seine saint denis face aux
terroristes quelques policiers
légèrement blessés
dommage donc debout salué l'action des
forces de l'ordre jean marie le guen ce
climat serein heureusement qu'il est
revenu c'est vrai ce mercredi nos matchs
des forces de l'ordre on imagine que
vous qui avez vécu tout ce qui s'est
passé depuis le mois de janvier et
encore cette fois où il avait rencontré
ces forces de l'ordre
qu'est ce que kelly quel est le message
qu'est ce qu'on se dit entre vous quand
y'a pas les caméras par c'est une
véritable admiration quand même sur à la
fois l'engagement et le
professionnalisme
vous parlez des forces de l'ordre vous
avez parfaitement raison je voudrais y
mettre aussi et voyez quelques minutes
avant de venir ici j'étais au conseil de
surveillance de l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière
je voudrais y associer les
professionnels de santé notamment les
hospitaliers l'assistance publique
je disais c'est personnel que non
seulement ils ont fait un travail qui du
point de vue des valeurs humaines est
tout à fait admirable mais au delà tout
ça dans cette
dans ce choc de violence les français
ont vu qu'il y avait des institutions
alors la police les pompiers le samu et
les hôpitaux publics qui était capacité
de résilience comme on espère la
résistance organisés les gens engagés
professionnels ils ont fait un travail
absolument
alors que les blessés arrivés par
dizaines que les plaies étaient très
très bouleversante
c'est de la chirurgie c'est pas de
chirurgie de guerre qui a été fait
c'était des chirurgies
qui a été fait dans des normes de
qualité tout à fait exceptionnelle faut
bien comprendre par exemple je parle de
ça parce que ça me touche un peu vous
aviez plusieurs équipes de spécialités
différentes qui intervenait
successivement autour d'eux
quand vous avez perdu un oeil à un
morceau de mâchoire que vous avez une
balle dans l'ue mais russe c'est pas la
même chose c'est des professionnels des
chirurgiens certes mais qui
interviennent chacun a sa spécialité
tout le monde était là toutes les
équipes étaient là et tournez tournez
tournez tournez prenez en charge dans
les calmes dans la sérénité dans
l'efficacité dans la qualité des soins
c'est admirable pour le message en tout
cas qui est passé quelques heures plus
tôt françois hollande était devant les
maires de france le congrès n'a pas pu
se tenir mais obtenue quand même à
rendre hommage par ce rassemblement un
discours empreint d'une très très très
large émotions avec notamment ce
discours de la maire de paris anne
hidalgo écouter mes amis le pari qui a
été frappé et notre pari à tous il
souffre mais il est debout
il regarde droit devant lui il est en
vie et il vivra
vive la république vive la france vive
les communes de france vise paris et
cinq minutes
donnez vos relations avec anne hidalgo
vous avez pu lui parle également oui
j'ai eu l'occasion de croiser il ya une
cérémonie enfin bruit de séance du
conseil de paris lundi exceptionnel on a
décalé les séances qui devait parler des
points m
la gestion de la ville qui sont bien
normaux et puis on a eu une séance
exceptionnelle qui était aussi très
émouvante d'unité nationale en tout cas
d'unités municipal voilà les propos
qu'elle tenait montre bien aussi
l'émotion fut la sienne
elle revient au parlement alors je dis
justement accélération sur le plan
législatif puisque six jours après les
attentats le parlement prolonge l'état
d'urgence perquisition possible sans
autorisation du juge assignation à
résidence la loi s'applique sur tout le
territoire pour une durée de trois mois
thibault le floch
ce matin les députés ont adopté
plusieurs articles du projet de loi
relatifs à l'état d'urgence
l'article 1 prévoit que cet état
d'urgence est prononcée pour une période
de trois mois
à droite certains députés estiment que
cette période est insuffisante et je
sais que trois mois ce sera trop court
monsieur le premier ministre
prolonger cet état d'urgence pour une
durée de 6 mois ne peut pas aujourd'hui
débattre d'un mois deux mois 6 mois 9
mois 12 mois personne ici dans cet
hémicycle n'en sais rien la période de
trois mois pour proroger l'état
d'urgence a finalement fait consensus
quels sont ceux qui sont pour contre
il est adopté l'article de voter sans
difficulté permet au ministère de
l'intérieur et au préfet d'ordonner des
perquisitions la nuit lors de l'état
d'urgence
même chose pour l'article 3 qui précise
que le gouvernement peut mettre fin à
l'état d'urgence par décret avant ces
trois mois les dissensions entre la
gauche et la droite se sont faits plus
forte sur le rôle des policiers
municipaux la droite souhaite que ces
agents puissent procéder à des contrôles
d'identité
un rôle dévolu à la police et à la
gendarmerie
le gouvernement promet d'étudier cette
question mais pas dans le projet de loi
actuel on ne comprend pas que vous soyez
d'une telle riches
dit et s'agissant de la police
municipale sur une simple contrôle un
simple contrôle d'identité
la question vous évoquez n'est pas une
question qui est fermé c'est une
question sur laquelle simplement nous
demandons à pouvoir prendre toutes les
précautions en droit au regard notamment
du respect des principes
constitutionnels rejetée par 198 voix
contre 128 cet amendement n'est
finalement pas adopté après cinq heures
de débats les six articles du projet de
loi ont été adoptés à 550 et une voix
contre 6 alors certains crenn et des
atteintes aux libertés publiques pendant
la durée d'application de cette loi ce
qu'il y aura des garde-fous notamment un
contrôle des contrôles est ce que les
parlementaires seront par exemple
informer alors d'abord notre
constitution est très précise il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont interdites
par rapport à des situations qui existe
dans d'autres pays ou dans d'autres
circonstances donc les autorisations de
dérogations sont très très précises
deuxièmement nous sommes nous avons fait
deux éléments qui sont majeurs dans le
dans l'état d'urgence il y avait
initialement dans la loi de 55 de 1955
des possibilités d'intervention sur la
presse nous avons écarté toute idée
expédié oui mais sur la presse j'ai
absolument aucune idée là c'est plutôt
les poèmes de propagande dialyse c'est
pas les problèmes d'information et
réseaux sans la formation donc
donc nous avons écarté toute idée
d'intervention sur la 1ere 2e
destruction de de liberté certaine
liberté
vous les avez cités c'est à dire le fait
que l'on puisse intervenir la nuit à
n'importe quelle heure on a vu qu'à
saint denis on est intervenue à quatre
heures du matin si on avait été dans une
loi
normal on ne pouvait pas intervenir
avant 6h du matin bon on est intervenu
donc de façon différente
donc ça c'est une première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que effectivement
il y aura un contrôle régulier du
parlement sur l'application de l'état
d'urgence qu'il ya un bilan
indépendamment même des contacts qui
doit avoir lieu entre le gouvernement et
les groupes parlementaires des deux
assemblées sur la gestion de l'ensemble
de la crise dans toutes ses dimensions
diplomatique militaire et sécurité
appliquées à partir de maintenant
oui absolument alors oui absolument le
contrôle sur l'état d'urgence d'un côté
l'information sur l'ensemble de la
situation de l'autre tout ça est
aujourd'hui en application dès
maintenant est juste une question
comment est ce que vous allez informé le
parlement est ce que c'est d'avoir des
séances comment ça va se passer
c'est aussi en informations de lançon de
la crise etc
ce sont ces le premier ministre qui va
recevoir les représentants des
différents groupes et différentes
commissions sur le contrôle de l'état
d'urgence et la commission des lois qui
va
se donner les moyens d'être informé de
contrôler ce qui se passe de façon
précise à redon on est dans un état qui
est jean tant est qu'il faut toujours
écouter d'ailleurs les interpellations
mais qui peuvent avoir lieu sur le fond
sur les principes mais on est dans
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
limitée dans le temps dans l'es1 moyens
contrôlée par des forces démocratiques
et commencer par la presse par le
contrôle parlementaire alors lors de ce
débat sur la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence le premier ministre a évoqué
la possibilité d'une attaque chimique et
bactériologique sur le sol français
est-ce que vous avez des informations
supplémentaires sur cette possible
menace est ce que nancy serait ce qu'il
a dit c'est que nous les lots qui se
préparait à l'ensemble du spectre de la
menace y compris celle là est ce qu'elle
est probable vraisemblablement non est
ce qu'elle est possible théoriquement
oui donc nous notre devoir c'est de ces
deux de nous préparer là et j'allais
bien protégé dans si elle devait
seulement la france a mis en place des
programmes depuis longtemps face dit m
rbc j'étais donc encore une fois ce
matin au conseil de mon hôpital en avons
parlé en public
effectivement un certain nombre de
dispositions non pas que ce soit
vraisemblable non pas que ce soit une
hypothèse sur lesquels on a des éléments
alors qu'est ce qui a comme élément en
dehors du fait qu'on examine tous les
cas de figure c'est que il y a eu vous
le savez en syrie il y avait des armes
chimiques
peut-être bactériologiquement tout cas
chimiques qui était dans le régime de
monsieur assad
bachar el assad et qui ont été pour le
en partie voler si tant est qu'on puisse
dire ça en tout cas que
l'état islamique s'est approprié et l'on
sait qu'ils ont l'état islamique dèche à
attaquer des résistants syrien avec du
gaz moutarde
donc il y a peut-être du gaz moutarde
peut-être de gaza mais après je vais
aller voir clair c'est un passionné un
petit peu pour passer de la possession
éventuel à une application c'est
extrêmement compliqué dieu merci
et donc voilà mais il ligne normes à
venir sur les mesures convenues sur
l'éventuelle raison d'un coût 600
millions d'euros
c'est ce qu'a dit en tout cas le
ministre des finances michel sapin a
écouté le président la république a
annoncé un ensemble de mesures pour
lutter contre le terrorisme et certaines
conduiront à mobiliser de nouvelles
ressources pour renforcer l'action de
l'état le gouvernement vous proposera
par amendement d'amplifier dès 2016 les
créations de postes dans trois
ministères
au total la mobilisation de ces nouveaux
moyens conduire à une dépense
supplémentaire sur le budget de l'état
de l'ordre de 600 millions d'euros en
2016 nous assumons à ce stade de la
discussion budgétaire
une dégradation du déficit à cette fin
nos partenaires européens ont très bien
compris que la production de nos
concitoyens est une priorité absolue en
ces moments et que les règles
européennes qui ne sont ni rigide ni
stupide pour reprendre les mots d'un
commissaire offre les marges de
manoeuvre adéquat
une seule question est-ce que c'est
l'assurance qu'il n'y aura pas d'impôt
supplémentaire pour les france est
clairement très clairement très
clairement comment vous faites bien je
vous avons dit qu'il n'y aura ni impôts
ni rabot sur les autres secteurs les
efforts sont faits ils sont déjà faits
importants mais momentanément y aura une
partie des dépenses qui sera plus
importante
voilà bon n'empêche pas les réactions
vont écouter une katia oui notamment sur
le pacte de stabilité qui seront remis
en cause et bien françois fillon a
critiqué cette remise en cause écoutez
c'était sur notre antenne
je crains que ce ne soit vraiment là une
astuce politicienne de françois hollande
les dépenses de sécurité qui l'a annoncé
j'ai fait le calcul
parce qu'il faut un certain temps avant
qu'elle monte en puissance en 2016 en
gros c'est 500 millions d'euros on n'a
pas besoin de rompre le pacte de
stabilité pour 500 millions d'euros il
est en train de se préparer à ouvrir en
grand les vannes de la dépense publique
à la veille de l'élection présidentielle
au prétexte que la france doit assurer
sa sécurité
je vous présente tout de suite gym ja
c'est notre partenaire du figaro.fr qui
est arrivé sur ce plateau nous réagir
dans un instant une réaction à ce que
vient de dire françois fillon prétexte
dit il
bon écoutez ce que françois fillon a
sans doute remarqué qu'on était quand
même dans un état particulier et
d'ailleurs je voudrais juste dire par
rapport à ce que disait michel sapin
c'est que là ce que nous faisons en
matière de dépenses y compris de
dépenses de sécurité intérieure nous le
faisons sans doute pour les concitoyens
français
mais c'est aussi parce que la france est
aujourd'hui le bouclier de l'europe en
grande part et celle lsl sur ces
terrains non je dis pas qu'elle est de
moins en moins seule elle peut avoir pas
toujours été comprise par l'ensemble de
ses partenaires mais nous sommes on est
en plein dans la tragédie en ce moment
du mali voilà nous sommes sommes là le
nous sommes aujourd'hui en première
ligne la france est en première ligne
est en première ligne en syrie elle est
en première ligne
en afrique elle est en première ligne
sur la question du terrorisme et de la
lutte antiterroriste et parfois parfum
l'homme et le prix oui bien sûr mais pas
nous sommes attaqués pas parce que nous
sommes en guerre contre le terrorisme
parce que le terroriste fait d'abord la
guerre à la france ou non ses valeurs de
son existence de ces libertés de son
mode de vie
bien sûr de son histoire de sa
géographie allez on y va c'est la loupe
du scan
tim avoue jean marie le guen on le sait
les attentats de paris ont lieu à trois
semaines du premier tour des régionales
c'est un contexte politique très
particulier est ce que dans ces
conditions tragiques la campagne des
régionales peut reprendre certains
disent le ps notamment on va reprendre
lundi prochain ce que ça vous paraît
raisonnable
d'abord la campagne officielle commence
lundi prochain et nous sommes et nous
avons décidé personne d'ailleurs n'a
demandé à ce qu'on remporte cette
échéance aura été en recul comme suez
était un recul aussi sur la coop 21
devant la menace des terroristes est
donc une victoire des terroristes donc
nous sommes debout et nous respectons
nos échéances et donc la loi et donc le
fait que la campagne officielle commence
lundi prochain peut faire de la
politique dans ces moments là et l'on
peut faire de la politique je pense tout
simplement la manière dont on le fait
est totalement différente c'est pour ça
que je pense que la manière dont le
gouvernement et cette majorité le fait
avec un souci de dignité de
rassemblement et la bonne façon de faire
et je ne crois pas que les polémiques un
peu stérile et procès d'intention et ses
voies utiles il n'y a pas besoin de feu
de jouer
l'agressivité pour montrer des
différences qui peuvent exister mais
pourquoi pourquoi partir dans des
discours qui viennent plutôt alimenter
la menace pourquoi il les divisions
surtout chez les françaises c'est pas
assez pas utile justement quelles
conséquences sur le scrutin est ce que
vous craignez que ces événements fasse
le lit du front national
est ce que c'est une crainte que qui
existe chez vous ou de la menace du
front national existaient
malheureusement maintenant depuis des
mois et des années
la réalité donc je ne veux pas je sais
pas ce que comment réagiront les connais
sarkozy dit que ça pourrait influencer
scrutin en faveur du front national
écoutez
je lui laisse la responsabilité de ses
propos
dans cette période moi je n'ai qu'une
chose à dire aux français c'est que il
faut aller voter
ils veulent vivre ils sont fiers de la
république alors qu'ils votent
voilà c'est toujours espérer un sursaut
de participation justement sur cette
élection que les gens se mobilisent dans
une sorte de wii sursaut républicain je
le crois je crois j'entends bien qu'un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes se
disent que les politiques mises en place
ont pas assez efficace il ya la
déception il ya de l'impatience ya des
interrogations il ya une incompréhension
tout ça existe mais maintenant ces
événements nous rappellent ce que nous
sommes nous sommes des citoyens c'est à
nous d'agir et ce moment le vote sera
aussi une manifestation très forte de
mobilisation républicaine et noël j'en
appelle moi par la sécurité contre la
sécurité
non je ne crois pas que qui peut être
contre la sécurité bien donc je pense
pas qu'il ya deux camps soient pour ou
contre la sécurité je pense que chacun
doit évoquer selon ses conceptions très
bien selon ses inclinaisons du moment
mais en fonction de l'idée que voter
c'est défendre la république il ya un
ministre qui joue un rôle essentiel
cette semaine c'est jean yves le drian
qui supervise l'intensification de des
opérations contre des chefs il est on
l'a presque oublié tête de liste en
bretagne
est-ce qu'il doit clarifier sa position
en vue de cette élection en désignant
par exemple son dauphin et en promettant
qu'ils ne sera pas président de région
puisque je crois que tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que il doit rester
ministre de la défense dans ces
conditions écoutez
toulon est d'accord ça très sensible
mais j'entends et j'écoute comme vous un
partir les compliments de ses complices
ont fait et en même temps vous
connaissez aussi les compléments qui lui
sont faits en tant que représentant
emblématique de la bretagne
bon voila moi je pense donc le choix
n'est pas fait mais il n'y a pas
forcément de choix à faire je pense que
d'ores et déjà jean yves le drian est à
la fois un excellent pour ne pas dire
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire le
meilleur ministre de la défense qui ait
eu la vème république et de l'autre côté
il est le leader emblématique de la
bretagne est sans doute lui plus que
tout autre depuis aussi vous souhaitez
que giresse voilà vous souhaitez qu'il
reste mais il est à la défense
en tout cas il est pleinement
aujourd'hui voilà chaque chose suffit
son heure mais en tout cas ne demandons
pas jean yves le drian de ne pas être ce
qu'il est il est à la fois le leader
emblématique de la bretagne et il est à
la fois le meilleur
très vite pourtant pour pour terminer on
vient d'apprendre ce matin qu'il y aura
une cérémonie nationale d'hommage aux
invalides vendredi prochain c'est une ce
sera une cérémonie sans précédent on
attend évidemment toutes les familles
des victimes qui seront très nombreuses
peut-être aussi des blessés est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus sur cette
cérémonie et surtout sur le ce que ça va
représenter 30
autant de temps réuni autant de gens
réunis aux invalides pour se sauver il
fallait il faut évidemment qu'il ya une
manifestation nationale et cérémonies
nationales ne sont pas il ya tellement
de victimes que tout ça évidemment les
enterrements appartiennent aux familles
mais il ya besoin de réunir la nation
dans un moment de deuil et ce sera ce
moment là je le crois que ce sera
quelque chose de très fort merci jean
marie le guen d'avoir été notre invité
merci à tous se retrouver la semaine
prochaine
bonne soirée